bienvenido a la meditación sobre
procrastinación irónicamente he estado
por casting 'no a hacer este vídeo así
es que estamos juntos en esto como en
todas las meditaciones la postura y la
respiración son muy importantes te
recomiendo que encuentres un asiento
agradable y firme si tus piernas no se
duermen también podría sentarte en el
piso pero intenta sentarte con la
espalda derecha con una muy buena
postura inhala
exhala
un poco más lento
un poco más profundo con cada
respiración
puedes relajar tus manos sobre tus
piernas a mí me gusta colocarlas con las
palmas hacia arriba
y cuando estés listo puedes relajar la
mirada y lentamente cerrar los ojos
inhalando y exhalando
ahora la procrastinación es muy
interesante
no estoy segura de si nosotros los seres
humanos somos los únicos animales de los
que sabemos que por casting han
podría valer la pena que alguien lo
investigara
pero nosotros definitivamente lo hacemos
una buena parte de la meditación se
trata de tomar conciencia de nuestros
pensamientos
y observar nuestros pensamientos y
darnos cuenta de que no somos nuestros
pensamientos
incluso aunque a veces nuestros
pensamientos parecen controlarnos o
abrumarnos así es que hagamos eso
tratemos de observar esos pensamientos
que nos están haciendo posponer algo que
necesitamos hacer
porque crees que estás posponiendo eso
te cuenta lo que me sucede a mí
normalmente generalmente lo que me pasa
es que tengo miedo de empezar porque
podría darme cuenta de que es más
difícil de lo que yo esperaba o que no
lo hago tan bien como yo esperaba o tal
vez me equivoqué tal vez no creo que
estoy suficientemente preparada para
empezar
otra forma de verlo es que nos estamos
enfocando demasiado en los resultados en
lugar de disfrutar el camino o disfrutar
lo que sea que estás posponiendo
porque es parte de esta experiencia
divertida he encontrado que cuando me
digo a mí misma sal
defínete por las acciones y no por los
resultados no te defines de acuerdo así
consigues un éxito o un fracaso
defínete como haciendo el esfuerzo
echándole ganas disfrutándolo riéndote
de ti misma riéndote de este misterio al
que le llamamos vida
y sólo poniendo un pie delante del otro
y dándonos cuenta de que no está tan mal
y después puedes poner el otro pie en
frente de ese
y seguir avanzando y lento pero seguro
te das cuenta de que estás avanzando
bastante y entre más avanzadas más lo
disfrutas especialmente si no lo estás
haciendo en el último minuto
ahora te voy a dar un minuto para que
repitas algo en tu mente que tal vez
puede interrumpir cualquiera de esos
pensamientos que te han estado
distrayendo de ponerte en acción en el
próximo minuto repite para ti
que realmente te gusta tomar acción que
tienes mucha suerte de estar en una
posición en la cual puedes tomar acción
el resultado es lo que es
y tú disfrutas la acción tienes suerte
de poder realizar la acción el resultado
es lo que es
sigue pensando en esto el próximo minuto
y yo regresaré no te preocupes
muy bien cuando estés listo toma un poco
más de conciencia sobre tus alrededores
siente tu cuerpo observa tu respiración
y lentamente abre tus ojos voy a
terminar con una última recomendación
algunas veces nos ponemos algo porque
sentimos que es muy grande o abrumador
lo que a mí me gusta hacer en esos casos
es decir hey vamos a dedicarle 20
minutos y al final de esos 20 minutos
vemos en dónde estamos si no veo ningún
progreso no hay problema solo fueron 20
minutos pero sí si avance excelente
trabajé los 20 minutos y me merezco
hacer una pausa si después de 5 ó 10
minutos de descanso estoy lista para
dedicarle otros 20 minutos perfecto y
bueno si después de 20 minutos quiero
seguir trabajando no me voy a detener
voy a seguir avanzando porque cuando
vemos las cosas así como hey solo me
estoy comprometiendo 20 minutos a hacer
esto no se siente tan intimidante tú
tienes el poder puedes decir hey yo
puedo hacer cualquier cosa por 20
minutos y puedo disfrutar cualquier cosa
por 20 minutos y entonces hasta vas a
querer hacerlo vas a creer sonreír y ser
buenísimo haciéndolo y así no sólo basta
avanzar sino que te la vas a pasar
bastante bien tómelo con esa mentalidad
divertida disfrútalo sonríe
solo empieza a hacerlo y creo que vas a
descubrir que procrastinar menos